Okay, let's talk now about the size of Donald
Trump's much touted jobs numbers.
They're actually not that good.
So we're going to dig into the numbers today.
Now remember, we've been doing these economic
analyses lately.
Remember Donald Trump claimed that his stock
market numbers are the best, and last week
we looked and it turns out that over their
first three years, Barack Obama's numbers
for the stock market growth were significantly
better than Donald Trump's stock market growth.
During his first three years, we looked at
debt and deficit.
Remember that Barack Obama saw slower deficit
growth and even in some years there was year
over year deficit reduction.
Straight up.
While Donald Trump has overseen some of the
biggest deficit increases in a long time.
And then we get to Donald Trump's claims about
jobs.
It turns out that during Donald Trump's first
three years, job growth slowed down to where
Barack Obama left off at the end of his presidency.
Now all the normal caveats here, there is
no one number that tells you everything you
need to know about how the economy is doing.
That applies to all of this stuff, stock market,
unemployment rate, job creation, whatever.
But when you compare the numbers, you see
that Barack Obama during his last three years
in office created 8.1 million jobs and Donald
Trump during the three years that followed
created 6.6 million jobs.
This is a greater than 18% reduction in job
growth under Donald Trump per the numbers
from the Bureau of labor statistics.
To put it a different way, if we want to think
about it monthly under the Trump economy,
we are gaining 182,000 jobs per month on average
and during Barack Obama's last three years
where he handed the economy over to Donald
Trump, the economy gained 224,002 24 under
Obama, one 82 under Trump.
Now there are two things to understand here.
One of those is estimates versus revisions.
The first Friday of each month we, unless
it's the first of the month, in which case
it might be the second Friday.
We get job creation estimates from the previous
month and those make headlines, but later
those numbers are fine tuned or adjusted and
they are finalized.
We get the final actual numbers and under
Donald Trump, often the estimates are higher
than the actual numbers we eventually get.
Now, if you present these numbers to Trump
or to his acolytes, they'll say, well, Trump's
creating higher quality jobs or wages are
higher or up under Donald Trump's job creation
or whatever.
Those are different arguments and we can research
those numbers if those are the goalposts that
they want to move to.
But they have been talking about job creation
and the bottom line is that job creation slowed
about 20% under Donald Trump.
This is a sort of rinse, repeat and go back
to the beginning with the lies.
They brag about stocks, we look at the numbers.
Well, the first three years under Obama were
stronger than the first three years under
Trump.
Oh, well then they come up with some reason
Obama was in the middle of a recovery and
it's expected that you would have bigger stock
market growth, whatever.
But then later they say Obama's recovery was
actually terrible.
Well, I thought you cited it as the reason
why the numbers were better than Trump's numbers.
It's just sort, it's a circle.
It's a never ending circle.
So then they brag about jobs, but then we
look at, well actually job growth slowed when
Donald Trump took over.
So then they switch and they'll brag about
growth as they recently have been GDP growth.
But remember that Donald Trump promised four
to 6% GDP growth and we actually got 2.9 in
2019 it's an endless cycle.
It's not really about arguing with them about
the numbers.
And as we've been talking about, there's really
no point in arguing with Trump.
It's about the numbers.
It doesn't matter.
They're going to rationalize whatever it is
that they believe to be true or what you can
convince them is true.
They're still going to rationalize it away.
We're not going to win this 2020 election.
Um, by convincing Trumpists that the economic
numbers are different than the ones that they
have been told or that they believe are true.
But the point is to understand that because
it's this endless loop, we just need to ignore
the Trumpists.
They're going to do their thing.
Trump's going to do his rallies and he's going
to lie and they're going to be fired up and
cheer and believe everything he says.
We need to activate the people that already
know Trump's it has asked her, but may not
be planning to vote just nine months from
now.
Let's take a quick break.
Make sure you're following me on Instagram
at David dot Pacman, and while you're there,
follow the show on Instagram as well.
At David Pakman show, we'll take a quick break.
Radio host, Tom Hartland joins me next to
talk about his great new book